alors c'est la vierge d'origine
non non non c'est la vie qui a été
rénové
après deux ans d'absence il ne la
reconnaissent même plus éblouissante
grandiose les habitants de velars sur
ouche en ont plein les yeux contents de
la voir revenir abbaoui en bas oui moi
je leur dis oui on est ensemble la voix
magnifique dollé comme ça je vais pas
penser qu' on la verrait et on va la
voir de loin parce qu'on la voit sur la
joute et les beignets statu quo à dori
13500 feuille d'or six mois de travail
c'est ce qu'il aura fallu pour restaurer
la vierge à l'enfant jésus
depuis hier après-midi la statue est
exposé en contrebas de la chapelle notre
dame d'étang la métamorphose est à la
mesure de ce chantier hors norme qui a
déjà coûté 1,2 million d'euros
huit ans pour collecter des fonds une
statue de huit tonnes à démanteler et
surtout un hélitreuillage spectaculaire
en mai 2013
il a fallu déposer la statue de toute
façon pour sa restauration mais
également faire des travaux importants
au niveau des pierres de de la coupole
et au niveau des pierres des contreforts
de ce qu'on appelle la tour lanterne
prochaines étapes de la restauration
consolidait le bas de la chapelle avant
cela l'événement tant attendu se tiendra
en milieu de semaine prochaine notre
dame d'étang regagnera les cieux du haut
de la colline elle veillera à nouveau
sur la vallée de l'ouche